ich finde das video vom spiel gehabt
wird josef löffl kommt zu einem neuen
video
hast du dich für kinder gibt es viele
kleine rote max wieder starten heute
leute reisen wir zurück in der zeit denn
das heutige video heißt erkläre diesen
post wir haben von uns gegenseitig sehr
sehr viel post draußen wird die
teilweise schon lange her sind wenn
jetzt gegenseitig zeigen und den anderen
bitten zu erklären was da eigentlich
abgegangen ist okay was fangen wir an
ich hab dank facebook durchsucht das
auch mal in facebook durchsucht youtube
durchsucht aber nichts gefunden ganz
kurz vor deren aussagen als max eine
ganz alte facebook ausgelöst
ich leider nicht also wenn ihr gleich
mal bitte was ging auf die hilfe sehr
gut dass dieser staat so aus wie ein
pärchen was nach dem winter so
aufgewertet und kurz erklärt das war
karneval
wir waren kurz und ich habe mein wort
falsch getippt
es war das erste mal seine absichten
karneval würdest du [ __ ] [ __ ] ich
dann okay
es war leichter haben noch einige backup
stadt und das werden sie einfach weil
leute sommer hat geht wieder umbenannt
man ja also passt überaus natürlich auch
wunderschöne introduction schaffen
okay leute hier hat sich der junge
sebastian aufgelehnt gegen einen
weltkonzern und hat sich da ja der
mittelfränkischen sprach bedient
verdammte kacke all der strichpunkt
lichtteilchen haus wieder ägyptische
kopten oder die kette erst jetzt dazu
brauchen wir geld hat das gesetz wird
dies ändern
folgendes alter erinnert an brachte max
dann hab ich auf deinem facebook-account
post von vom 10
mai 2012 ist ein youtube link gepostet
und als text dabei ich sag muss jetzt
sagen und zu bündeln
[Gelächter]
via facebook nur leute in seinem alter
wenn man hat doch seine tage auf den
arbeitgeber sucht die ihr wollt ist bei
apple arbeitet personal dafür sehen fand
es gut dass jetzt ganz normal
auffrischen und aktuellen aufarbeiten
die slawische schwer haben die zu 50 an
video erklärt wurde damals einfach so an
die jetzt sind sind waren damals noten
dann habe ich hier ein kleines
schmankerl von youtube dichters beispiel
gewinner hängig das dazugehörige bild
dafür noch mehr aktualität und es wegen
der vorgänge aber auch sechs haben weil
das geil ist dieses gemalt und was ja
was ich dazu sagen wichtig mehr damals
war konnte noch besser ok mag's dann bin
ich ja oft ein youtube katar ich werde
darüber sind wir uns das video vom spiel
gehabt
[Gelächter]
zusammengelegt
ich habe glaube ich nicht sagt bestimmen
die schrift dass wir so abschießen
dürfen jetzt ist es echt einkaufen
machen an das beste ist jetzt hat dem
video bei diesem video später
kommentierte ja wie erklärst du nord und
gucken was ist für dich dein kopf
durchgesetzt dass das ist ein player
oder handy leute anscheinend war
teamsitz oder sonne
warum habt ihr sonst diese glocke ging
vors gesicht gehalten vielleicht war
damals von justin bieber hält zu haben
auch der spitze angelangt was war so
schlimm wie nie und wenn nötig halte ein
satirisches zeichen gegen die verletzung
dieses kanadischen jugend schnaps oder
ja einen strip-club hast du von fünf
tagen drei wichtige beiträge und zwar
einmal das erste frau ausgespannt und
ist als feier aus
[Gelächter]
der klassiker mit bezugsrecht musste
schon so sprechen die leute am werk
und wir haben es damals noch so
zugelassen hätten wir nicht machen
wollen
das service ist allein sind facebook
seine welt komplett das hier will keiner
so konnten rausgehauen ich 2000 heftiger
da damit auch demütig herausgefunden
seitdem das war von vier jahren hat dein
konto schritt um schritt einfach nur
grottenschlecht verschlechtert also
sondern dass man kann nicht besser
wusste ich schon mal passieren dass man
hörte dachte das ist wieder ein
klassiker war die l 830 mio wie klappt
es noch die idee dass der lack so lustig
und der name ist ungefähr so
siebenstelliger dafür haben wir einfach
wir miteinander geprägt war beste zeit
auf jeden fall das weder der
wissenschaften starken schöne woche und
bleibt